welcome back jasper america's dog sadly
passed away over the weekend he was nine
years old but packed in more years of
living than most bipeds at the villages
for years the furry fella provided this
show with plenty of laughs through his
many appearances and dana's endless
endless endless references in one more
thing but we will all miss jasper here's
a look back
well here he is
we've waited for him for a long time
it's jasper for real it's his birthday
he's one year older
he's america's dog i didn't know you had
a dog oh yeah i have a dog he can
squeeze into any
possible chair that we're going to sit
in keeps me warm i don't even need a
blanket jasper we did this about a
hundred times that night he it never got
old for his time never got old he just
never learned that it was coming it's
been a year since america's dog has been
on the five but here he is back jasper
bishop perino
[Music]
america's dog jasper is joining us much
to greg's disappointment although i do
think he actually kind of likes him
jasper say hello to your fans he is much
better behaved this year than last year
he's getting older so it's time now for
one more thing um i'll go for
jasper's birthday
he's six years old today this is he
comes every yard on his birthday jesse
can't believe his
good fortune
[Music]
hey jasper want a treat okay there you
go
obviously jasper can sit that's very
easy you can also catch as you can see
catch
a high five
[Music]
oh all right so uh here you go this will
be right here all right and then i got a
whistle so this is called the crying
whistle whenever you start crying i just
blow it and then they like
i don't think i'll cry thank you so much
i know that that probably pained you i
put that whole thing together over the
weekend
thank you so much yes it was it was very
quick um
he didn't really show any symptoms until
about 10 days ago or so and i go of
course i was a great google doctor and i
thought he had a kidney stone um and he
was at the vet uh anyway uh it was
cancer and it was everywhere and um so
he had a very peaceful goodbye on
saturday so it's very sad but i would
also say i feel this tremendous amount
of gratitude um for him and his life all
he gave me and but also
but like that it's fun to look back
about the show and the audience and how
much everybody seemed to really get a
kick out of him and it connected people
from all walks of life politics had
nothing to do with it and he was a
really wonderful champion a total legend
uh i would say who's great dog
a famous french philosopher once said
in the depth of winter i finally learned
that within me there lay an invincible
summer that was camus oh thank you
what does that have to do with america's
dog
i think that's what you're feeling right
now oh okay that's how i'm gonna
play this out dana but i would like to
say one thing i did sleep with your dog
yes
when you invited me over for dinner and
i asked if i could spend the night
because i was too inebriated to go home
and i ended up sleeping on the futon
yeah with jasmine
couch if you remember
there was a pull-out couch right well i
had a wonderful night
on your pull-out couch
with jasper who i love and uh and then i
got rookie and now i know what made your
heart so big dog
yes dog love
you know i'll tell you dana i mean the
the one thing i'm the first people to
call me yeah but the one thing that that
gives me a sense of peace is the rainbow
bridge you know and and
people should google it it's where dogs
go and and animals go and they they're
able to play and run and play with each
other and there's a beautiful rainbow
and uh it gives me a lot of satisfaction
i'm sure you've read it it's uh and then
up for the little picture five fan photo
shops really made jasper a star i think
um he's loved this show he loved jasper
and he made this for me on saturday to
announce jasper's passing so there he is
at the rainbow bridge so thank you five
fan we appreciate that oh all right
harold do you have a philosopher um
mine is this great american philosopher
jesse waters
once told me like we we have three dogs
and we lost our dog 12 years ago we said
we would never get a dog for another
year and when a week later we had a dog
six months everywhere our second dog
you're two years ago
so yeah so um
i'm almost tearing up because i was not
a dog person so i married my wife and
now i can only imagine what
[Laughter]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else